it's a pleasure to introduce our speaker
dr. Sonia Sonia Anja who presently is in
CDC as senior advisor for nine community
diseases Center for Global Health in CDC
Atlanta dr. Angela did her undergraduate
work at Indiana University where she
majored in political science journalism
which actually relevant to watch dear
later receive her MD from UCSF became a
resident at Brigham and women in the
primary care program she also obtained a
degree from London School of Tropical
Medicine while a resident in Boston and
then they run an mph from you know some
Michigan she then did fellowship as RWJ
a clinical scholar I'd use a Michigan
following that was recruited immediately
in 2004 to New York City the center of
activities for public health in service
of the people of New York let as you
know about the mayor of New York City
and dr. Tom Frieden who was the head of
the Department of Health and Mental
Hygiene in New York City she was
director of cardiovascular disease
prevention and control program for seven
years and during that time she
accomplished several areas which made
the news still in the news for example
theory of trans-fat in new restaurants
national saw reduction initiative
establish a nutritional standard for
food procured by New York City
government agencies and clinical quality
improvement initiative for blood
pressure and cholesterol control many of
these obviously on is still in the
public domain because there is still
controversy if you read last night
Norman in German medicine there are two
perspectives on the front page of new
German medicine regarding the latest
attempt controlling the amount of sugary
drinks in New York and so she was in
really in the midst of all of these
changes occurring in the area of Public
Health in New York City she then moved
on to Atlanta to become senior advisor
for diseases in Center for Global Health
where she oversees all activities in
this area for CDC she is represent CDC
in evolution install medicine in this
area and really is working in the area
that's becoming increasingly important
in the poor region of the world shall
see multiple awards including a way as a
medical student Partners Award for
Excellence when a resident at Brigham
distinguished service award New York
City part of Health and Mental Hygiene
interestingly she continues to write
about her experiences in multiple
journals including others into medicine
science and editorial a couple of years
ago and journals are between ology and
public health so it's really a pleasure
to have you idea
thank you it is um it's such a pleasure
to be here I I spend a lot of time on
the road in other countries as is the
job in global health so when I have the
opportunity to stay home in the United
States and talk to colleagues here and
learn a little bit about what you're
doing and share what we're doing it's
it's a it's a great treat and I think
it's increasingly important as we
struggle in this changing climate this
economic and health environment to try
and figure out how to work appropriately
in the United States to address some of
our greatest challenges many of the
opportunities for learning exist not
only here but abroad as well and so to
the extent that we continue this really
important interchange I think we're all
the better off for it so I'm gonna talk
to you today about decrease in global
non communicable diseases by reducing
risky behavior I like that term risky
behavior we'll go through and sort of
tear it apart and build it up again but
I think it's something that we we
associate with our individual actions
and I think by the end of this
presentation we'll you understand a
little bit more about how we think of it
from a public health perspective and
what our responsibilities are to help
support changes and individuals and make
things easier for us so my fans
financial disclosures I have no relevant
financial relationships to this
presentation and so briefly is an
outline over the next 45 minutes or so
50 minutes or so I'm going to talk to
you first about the context for global
non communicable diseases
talk about the environment in which we
exist the global community talked about
a little bit of the epidemiology related
to non communicable diseases and the way
in which we're facilitating these
so-called risky behaviors and then go
through a discussion about how to modify
risk by giving examples related to the
greatest and most important risk factors
related to non-communicable diseases
hypertension and tobacco use we'll talk
about the community and the clinical
context it's the latter being perhaps
more relevant to what you do every day
for your work but all of us exist in the
community and are influenced by it and
then ultimately talk about some lessons
learned and then bring us to some
conclusion about how we can really move
forward and make a difference together
so our world is large and it's diverse
and yet it's becoming increasingly
familiar and similar for the first time
in human history more
humans live in urban areas men in rural
areas and so we're increasingly sharing
the risk associated and the
opportunities associated with those
physical environments our environments
in terms of retail shopping the economy
are also increasingly familiar this is
an interesting list that I pulled that
looks at the top ten wheat tailors in
2011 and on the left-hand side is the
list of those in North America on the
right it's worldwide and what you'll see
immediately is in the top 10 list
Walmart and Kroger both feature in the
worldwide in the top 10 list and if you
go out to the top 24 list eight of those
top 10 companies that you see there in
North America feature globally in the
top 24 retails stores which means that
these are places where not only we are
shopping but other consumers in our and
our colleagues around the world are
shopping and being exposed to similarly
when we look at the top 10 food and
beverage companies so the foods that we
eat every day
you also see this globalization that's
occurring again in North America
compared with worldwide you look at
Nestle Kraft PepsiCo these are all
featuring globally and other products
that we buy every day from Unilever etc
made while they may not have been on
this top 10 list in North America they
certainly continue to feature globally
so again not only our urban physical
environments are becoming familiar but
the products that were exposed to as
well are much more cement a similar as
our the risk factors for death when we
look at low middle and income high
income countries so this is an
interesting slide that ranks deaths
attributable to leading risk factors by
country income level in 2004 high income
is is indicated by the dark blue middle
by the light blue and low income by the
yellow and two things I want to point
out first of all is that high blood
pressure in tobacco use is the leading
cause leading attribute or respecter to
death not only in high-income countries
but in middle and low income countries
around the world and also we'd like to
point out how how much how important
they are relative to other risk factors
not to suggest that all of these risk
factors aren't important but also just
to point out that there are some
commonalities that we have that if we
think about them constructively together
and think about solutions together some
of the solutions
as well as some of the problems may be
quite similar this slide looks at the
increasing burden of chronic
non-communicable diseases comparing 2008
to to what's projected in 2030 again
this looks at this epidemiologic
transition that's occurring in our world
and it illustrates that why at while in
high-income countries we may have
already reached the point of change and
there will perhaps not be much more of a
change in terms of the proportion of a
contribution of non communicable
diseases
low and middle income countries first
will be achieving those changes by 2030
and the second thing I want to point out
so if you look at the top sort of row of
pie charts on the far right as
low-income countries in 20 2008 and then
what's projected in 2030 you see this
remarkable increase in the contribution
of non communicable diseases
albeit now it's still a very large
contributor but will increase
dramatically and I think this points out
a couple of opportunities one is that
much of the transition that we've gone
through we've already reached and
overcome some of the challenges and some
we have not and there's a lot of
learning that can occur not only in
thinking in low and middle income
countries about what they could do to be
successful but also what they could
avoid what is the trajectory that we
took that if they took very conscious
and made very intentional decisions may
they not end up in the same place that
we've ended up it or could they get to
our level of health or a higher level of
health much more rapidly so the burden
of global sound communicable diseases is
daunting
this looks at total global deaths from
non-communicable diseases and what I
want to point out first of all is that
60 approximately 60% of all deaths
globally are due to non communicable
diseases about 80 percent of those
deaths occur in low and middle income
countries and second I'd like to point
out that cardiovascular disease and
cancer make up a very large proportion
followed by respiratory diseases and
diabetes and as a result those four
major diseases including because their
risk factors are shared have become the
focus and topic of a lot of energy and
innovation and implementation of
programming and efforts globally to
address non communicable diseases
to do nothing is not an option the
economic impact of non action around non
communicable diseases is huge the
Harvard School of Public Health working
with the World Economic Forum developed
these estimates in 2011 to look at the
impact of non action they looked at
first accumulative out poke lot output
losses from non action in 20 years by
the year 2030 and the estimated loss was
47 trillion dollars now that's a huge
amount of money and it quite frankly
when we get into these trillions of
dollars it means absolutely nothing to
me anymore it's just huge it's huge
that's all it is so I think the second
bullet is very helpful in that it sort
of puts it in perspective and 47
trillion dollars represents 75 percent
of the global GDP in 2010 so that helps
you kind of get your head around how
important non communicable diseases can
and will be if we aren't effective in
taking action globally the cost of
illness CVD model estimates an increase
of about 22 percent by 2030 this
threatens country level and global
development agenda so it becomes even
more relevant as we talk about the
global Millennium Millennium Development
Goals etc this is again something that
we can't overlook that we need to
incorporate it even though in low-income
countries it may not be the predominant
concern it will be and it will undermine
many of our achievements if we're not
careful so this is the way the global
community has organized this response
again it's really focusing on the common
risk factors looking at the major causes
of death with the intermediary of the
metabolic risk factors of concern so the
areas that have been most focused on in
terms of sharing information sharing
interventions include tobacco that focus
on poor diet harmful use of alcohol and
physical inactivity so now let's get to
risky behavior because again when we're
talking about these these diseases of
non communicable diseases they should we
talk about them as lifestyle diseases we
talk about them as if they're under the
control of the individual this slide and
you can repeat the slide in the United
States or any other country of choice is
looking at prevalence of obesity between
1980 and
2008 by gender women are on the right
men are on the left the red lines
indicate the prevalence in 2008 versus
the blue lines which is the prevalence
in 1980 and this is just a sampling of
countries and and what I think I'd like
to point out on this slide is that first
of all in both genders obesity is
increasing I'll be at somewhat in some
countries a little a little different
but not radically different second it's
increasing everywhere and third some
countries it's increasing it
astronomical we're like rate so this
makes you wonder did the whole world
just decide 20 years ago to decide not
to exercise or eat like every individual
in the world decide that or is there
actually some sort of global framework
that we've created that makes it easier
for people to make those choices it may
not be healthier choices I think I sort
of loaded the way I presented that
question to give you an answer but I
think it's really important and it's the
construct that we use when we talk about
these issues with patients as well and
that's not to decrease the empowerment
of the individual to change their life
but it's also important for us to
recognize you can't change things in
your life that aren't changeable per se
and so our responsibility from a public
health perspective is to look around and
say how have we created innovate an
environment to make it to enable those
patients to make the changes that we're
asking them and to enable us non
patients to make the healthy choices in
our community every day even if not
guided by a physician's advice again you
can only make choices based upon what's
available to you so you may have many
different choices in front of you but
that doesn't necessarily mean that there
is a healthy choice or an easy healthy
choice in front of you and I want to
remind us also about our history because
we seem to treat non communicable
diseases as radically different from
other public health threats that we've
had but let's think about the approaches
that we've used in the nineteenth
century in terms of public health
interventions have those actually relied
upon individual action to make the great
achievements that we've seen so do we
tell people or did we tell people that
responsible people boil their water did
we tell them to know their butcher to
avoid diseases did we tell them to just
get outside and get fresh air to avoid
crowds to keep a tidy house to take care
of your refuse it's simply not the case
we actually changed the environment in
which all of us operate to make sure
that there was clean and water running
straight out of the tap you didn't have
to wait for the water to be boiled that
there were restrictions and regulations
around the way in which our foods are
prepared that there is access to fresh
air and ventilation that we have places
where we don't necessarily have to
remain in crowds housing has changed and
the way in which we we pick up rubbish
on the roadside is quite different so
all of these things are things that we
have done to create an environment that
enables people to live healthy and to
avoid infectious diseases and one may
argue that's exactly what we need to do
with non communicable diseases I also
want to make this transition because we
talked a lot about this in public health
but one of the things that we're not
very good at particularly in the United
States given the way in which our health
care environment has evolved is we talk
about the clinical environment it's
totally separate from the public health
environment and so as we think about
these interventions that we do in the
community I think we also need to think
about role and responsibility and
opportunity in the clinical environment
to contribute to public health advances
and so as we talk about enabling
patients to make the best choices I
think we also need to talk about
enabling providers to make the best
choices so are we really enabled to make
the best choices and provide the best
care for our patients and are they easy
choices also because we as providers are
in the same situations as patients are
if the choice is not an easy choice we
may not make it for our patient so when
we we think about treating
garden-variety hypertension for example
this is not complicated this is not
rocket science as much as I'd like to
think that it's very important that we
know how to treat hypertension very well
it's actually not that complicated to do
it and yet it is complicated to do it
right it doesn't require that much of an
intellectual decision-making but we have
many intellectual decision-making
opportunities to make along the way and
that can make it complicated and
difficult and that can ultimately make
the best choice a difficult choice to
make so we have to prescribe a specific
medication out of all of a whole
plethora of opportunities monitor labs
blood pressure titrate medication
provide the patient to access to
self-management tools support them in
their adherence follow-up for scheduling
titrate their medications again
follow-up monitor educate we have to
keep doing all of these things again and
again and again for each patient and to
the extent that we have to consciously
think about every single one of
decisions and create a new environment
for the patient to do it are we actually
making it easy for us to achieve in the
clinical environment what we're trying
to tell patients to do in their
community environment so this is the way
we typically think about improving
health we can use a high risk approach
where we've sort of lob off the top
group this is what we do as providers we
look at people with blood pressure of
above 140 over 90 treat them execute
that that's one way to treat patients
into advanced population health and it's
an important segment of the population
because they're very high-risk
population so the interventions can have
great impact then there's what we
learned from particularly f-free rows of
British epidemiologist who've made the
argument very clearly and salient Lee
that if you reduce risk by just a little
bit across a very large population you
have an even greater impact than if you
increase risk a whole lot across a very
small high-risk population that's not to
say it's one or the other but it is a
complimentary approach to it so that
when we think about the two of these
approaches together ultimately this is
really where population health is and
this is where we are all really players
also not only in the domestic but in the
global community okay so let's think
about the different paradigms and the
way we can have greatest impact versus
lowest impact and the way and where we
should think about investing very
limited resources this is a diagram
developed by doctor dr. Thomas Frieden
in 2010 it was published and we've been
sort of bantering it around for a long
time and I put it in in presentations
and have interesting discussions
afterwards there's a lot of discussion
debate about that I think what it really
does do is think helped us sort of
organized in our minds and perhaps it's
not as clean as this but organized in
our minds how we make investments and
how those investments have impact so the
argument here is that if we counsel and
educate people for example one by one
it's a very small impact because it
requires a great amount of resources and
we can only reach a small number of
people if however we really focus on the
socio-economic factors or some of these
at the bottom end where we change the
context for the way in which people live
we can reach a very large group of
people perhaps with less resources now I
will tell you that I'm very troubled by
this I'm troubled by it because we
talked about this and I think this is
correct that where some of the greatest
changes can occur is through a chain
and moderating socioeconomic factors but
the truth is when we work in public
health we hang out in this change in the
context area we don't really move down
into that out of the area I think it's
because our sphere of influence is
public health practitioners is that we
don't necessarily make decisions about
the economy but as we move into non
communicable diseases and think about
them because it is about lifestyle
because it is about the framework in
which we all live these economic factors
are even more important so we have to
figure out a way to actually engage in
the agents and actors that influence the
socio economic factors so in summary
there are ways in which we can make a
big difference there ways we can make a
difference one by one we can do it
populations at large but all together
collectively we have to think about each
of the elements and think about where
our investments are and make the best
decisions for the communities so I'm
going to talk a little bit now about
hypertension raise blood pressure now
just to give specific examples and faces
to the broader discussion that we just
went through hypertension is the leading
cause of non communicable disease and
death as I showed you earlier the
prevalence is about one third of adults
worldwide have hypertension similar to
the estimates in the United States
that's about a billion people in the
world that have hypertension the cost of
non optimal blood pressure control is
three hundred seventy two billion
dollars in 2001 estimated to be which is
about 10% of overall health expenditures
globally domestically it is about 10%
also in some countries in in Asia
Eastern Europe it's it's much higher
than that Latin America it's a little
bit lower than that but it is globally
around 10 percent and if blood pressure
levels remain unchanged the health care
costs over the next 10 years are
estimated to be a trillion globally so
this is not a small problem it's a
problem that's very expensive and it's a
problem that if we're able to address we
can have great impact this son this
reflects the distribution of blood
pressure in the United States and I use
it because I think it's important to
illustrate this sort of divide of where
the clinical environment can reach and
where it can't reach so the green and
the yellow are those people who have
hypertension those are the ones that if
they came into your office you would
react and respond the rest of them those
with normal and with pre
hypertension maybe the ones that
prehypertension you would have time to
talk with them about it and it depends
on what their other diseases are that
your treatment day you may just avoid it
because it looks pretty good but
otherwise the rest of that population
the vast majority of Americans certainly
those with pre hypertension and
percentage of those with normal blood
pressure are a higher risk but we'll
have no intervention at all and this is
where the population interventions that
we were talking about can actually reach
and that's why they're important to
consider in the portfolio of responses
that we have to disease this is an
interesting study done by Bivins Domingo
published in the New England Journal
where she looks at the impact of a
variety of different interventions I put
this here to illustrate and compare the
impact of treating those with
hypertension and these are all patients
with hypertension treating them
according to the all hat protocol in the
United States and the second is looking
at the impact of salt reduction on the
population in the United States this is
not to Pit one against the other but
just sort of to illustrate that they
actually the two of them together both
will have a remarkable impact first of
all and second of all they have a very
similar impact and so the that the two
sorts of approaches that we have again
here in terms of numbers are are similar
and complementary in with respect to
hypertension so let's talk a little bit
about salt sodium and diet and this is
what I call the dietary disconnect
because since the 1980s the u.s. dietary
guidelines have been produced and we've
been talking to people about how to eat
well and what they should eat and we all
know this and we think it's important
for people to be educated but this is
the daily recommendation from the
American Heart Association on based upon
their revisions from 2006 and what the
u.s. mean intake is and you'll see that
there's a disconnect clearly what we're
telling people to do and what they're
doing is quite different so when it
comes to sodium the recommended intake
is 2,300 milligrams unless you are
greater than fifty one african-american
have hypertension diabetes or chronic
kidney disease which happens to be most
adults then your intake should be around
1500 milligrams and yet the mean intake
is over 3,000 milligrams of sodium per
day and you'll see similarly we're
variably successful than the other
recommendations so what can we do about
this dietary disconnect
this is from all the years that I spent
at the health department sort of
thinking about the sphere of influence
and how complicated health is and making
good decisions this is what I came up
with this is the control that we have
and I'm and I think our early boils it
down to like you know what's around is
what you eat I think that's what comes
down to right you can make some
decisions but what's around is what you
eat and when it comes to sodium it's
even more important because most of the
salt that we everyday comes from
processed in a restaurant foods it's
already in the food at the time that we
buy it it's not what we're adding at the
table it's not what we're adding when
we're cooking it's already there so
again that's that individual in that
food environment 77% of the salt that we
get every day is already in the food and
then when we start to look at the other
areas that we can influence when we're
cooking it's a very small amount about
11% that's added in the home or during
cooking this is the case in high-income
countries in low and middle income
countries it varies the contribution of
salt during cooking is much higher
certainly but there are some very clear
specific condiments that are processed
that play a big role in contributing to
sodium intake this is fish sauce in a
supermarket in Thailand it got cut off
but it literally covered the entire
aisle and then it went back around the
other side of the aisle so I imagine
that people have their favourites that
they go for one thing to be aware of
also is that well we have been it's a
luxury and I I can't even imagine the
time where we couldn't turn over a
package and see the the nutrients on the
back if we wanted to no that is not
necessarily the luxury that most people
have in the world that labeling is not
mandatory in most countries and and it's
done even when it's done in a voluntary
fashion it's not necessarily regulated
so well you see all of these products
here and while many of them may have
labels on them they may be variably
enforced in terms of whether or not
they're truly representing the package
and I'm not speaking specifically to
Thailand and on their with respect to
enforcement but but labeling is not
mandatory there and it's not mandatory
in many places so these products while
they're processed that doesn't
necessarily mean that even if you
purchase them and you try to make
different decisions that you have that
choice because the information may not
even be there so what can we do about it
so the
this is the spectrum of opportunities
for sodium reduction and I've sort of
organized it in terms of those that may
have come up and have been discussed and
be starting at the top the ones that
reach the broader population versus
those that rely more upon individual
action so that one of the areas that's
been discussed and it actually has an
evidence base for it is targeting
industry reformulations and working on
reformulating the products that are out
there and the UK has really taken the
lead on this introducing their salt
reduction initiative it's probably about
13 or 14 years ago now and continuing on
where they've actually worked with
industry to set targets for sodium
reduction and then follow that over time
and have actually documented reductions
in sodium intake in the population again
this is because they're targeting the
greatest source or contributor of salt
in the diet similar to the United States
it's in processed in restaurant foods so
that is a very reasonable approach to
think about if you're working in a
higher income country where the reliance
upon processed foods is much greater
other different variations of that is
are setting policies for the nutrition
and food when it's purchased focusing on
feeding programs that are reaching
vulnerable populations and putting
requirements on the amount of sodium is
in those foods I'm focusing on labeling
which certainly has an impact where
people can make decisions about products
not only on packaged foods but
increasingly discussions around
restaurant foods and you'll see
mandatory labeling I'm actually
appearing in a number of environments
shortly in restaurant foods different
ways in which one can think about
marketing lower sodium products pricing
I haven't seen as much work on but it
certainly come up in terms of discussion
media awareness campaigns have been
shown to be effective although informing
individuals really doesn't make much of
a difference if they don't have the
tools to take action so it needs to be
complemented with something people can
do changing ingredients for home cooked
prepared foods is another option and
then changing habits of cooking for home
prepared foods and how people salt at
the table so I want to talk a little bit
about this targeting industrial
reformulations because it's a relatively
simple approach and it's an approach
that has is really picking up speed
globally in a lot of middle-income
countries as well as higher income
countries
mentioned the UK I did it I will when I
was in New York City this is an approach
we use for the national assault
reduction initiative where we partnered
with other state and city governments
across the United States Canada has
implemented and is working forward on
one of these initiatives and more
recently Brazil Argentina and Colombia
all in the Americas have introduced
target driven reductions in sodium
working with industry Australia China
has in there Sean dong province and
approach to this as well so it's
something people are really thinking
about the idea is quite simple
you create a database you need to create
a database that has all of the brand
products and their nutrition information
in it and from this huge database you
break all of the products into
categories so for example bread is the
largest contributors sodium in the u.s.
diet so you create a bread category then
you have to break the bread category
into a whole bunch of sub category it's
because breads are produced differently
and the opportunity to reduce sodium in
the production of products depends on
the way the products produced so you may
end up with rolls and other products so
then you have subcategories you look at
the mean sodium in that category so for
example here's an example of sodium in a
category it could be any we could just
pretend that it's a roll for example I
mean it's probably not a roll because
this sodium is quite high in this
product but um less for the assumption
make it's it's probably more like a
sausage or something so you have this
distribution and you sit down with
industry and you say this is what I know
you're producing these products this is
what I know about this category whoops
and and you you negotiate and discuss
how you might shift the bell curve so
again this is a little bit about similar
to what Rose was doing right but we're
doing it in the food environment we want
a shift exposure to a risk so if we
actually shift the way the risk is in
and of itself we shift it against the
population so then one would argue you'd
be like it for it in 2014 to get down to
about 400 milligrams you set the target
and eventually the sodium and those
products goes down you're not trying to
reduce just an individual product you're
trying to shift the sodium in the whole
category itself so that the choice for
individuals is not about a higher or
lower sodium product the choice is about
picking from a selection of products
that all have lower sodium in them
ah there it worked so we've shifted the
bell curve which would ideally be
reflected in the population as well so
what have we learn from this approach in
changing the environment in the food
environment focusing on sodium
reductions these are some of the general
learnings that I think come from this
first of all that multi sectoral
partnerships will be key right so
industry must be at the table for sodium
reduction for example they produce the
product they need to be partners in this
they are less traditional partners from
a public health perspective but they
must be at the table and you can repeat
that every time you think about some
other risk factor related to the health
environment we're going to need to pull
in multi sectoral partners and we're
gonna have to do it in a way that
reflects a potential conflict of
interest again because there are
economies here we've done this in the
medical environment related to the
pharmaceutical industry and we can
certainly do it again as we speak about
it in public health with respect to
other opportunities for change the other
thing is we really need new methods of
data collection monitoring and
surveillance so I described to you this
database that needed to be created that
was a brand new database that didn't
exist the standard reference nutritional
database doesn't include this kind of
information we're going to need to do
this we need to be creative in the way
that we monitor and serve and do
surveillance on non communicable disease
and we're going to need a global
learning community because as I talked
about we figured out some options in
high-income countries we still don't
know what to do about rolling sodium in
foods when they're produced in the home
or added by the individual and we need
to learn that we may not have the right
environment to learn it here but it's
relevant here so lessons that we might
be learning from other countries that
are experimenting this for example in
China or in other places could be quite
relevant here and that's where this
exchange becomes so important okay
quickly I want to talk about tobacco and
because it's quite different from
hypertension than the sodium environment
because the actors of tobacco industry
is very different from those that are in
the food environment just by the type of
product that the tobacco industry
produces so this is smoking prevalence
by males and females again this is by
country you see across males on the
right-hand side females on the left-hand
side and the key things take-home here
is it a lot of people smoke in a lot of
places men smoke more than women but
it's a problem everywhere and in some
place
this from males for example in Russia is
60% and greater right it was not so
different here in the United States not
that very long ago so we just keep that
in mind too but it where people are
globally is very different so what can
we do about that and what is the problem
so one-third of all deaths from
malignant neoplasms are due to tobacco
one-third of respiratory diseases
one-third of cardiovascular diseases so
if we can make a change in the people
smoking and tobacco use habits we can
make a huge change in the profile of
non-communicable diseases globally so
the World Health Organization Framework
Convention on tobacco control is really
really an interesting model for the way
in which one might work to change the
way in which countries deal with risk
factors related to non communicable
diseases so the World Health
Organization has actually had the the
the right to negotiate international
treaties ever since it was established
this is the first time it's actually
exercised that responsibility and right
and and it's in response to the
globalisation of the tobacco epidemic
and and is justified by reaffirming the
right of all people to the highest
standards of health 176 parties
countries are have signed on to this
that covers 90% of the world's
population and basically includes
measures to address or treaties or
agreements that these countries have
made agreements to address issues
related to the price of products to the
production of products to the products
themselves what's the content of the
nicotine in them etc how to regulate
that and also the places in which
tobacco may be used in order to
facilitate this there's something that's
been created that's called the empower
which is a set of evidence-based
measures which are recommended for
countries to implement in order for them
to meet the responsibilities of the FCTC
and they include monitoring tobacco use
and prevention policies so that
surveillance protecting people from
tobacco smoke user laws to prevent for
example smoking in indoor places
providing assistance to people to offer
to quit tobacco use warning people about
the dangers of tobacco use such as on
labels enforcing bans on tobacco
advertising and raising taxes on tobacco
so affecting the prices in New York City
this is an example of what's been done
with pricing so excise taxes are the top
prices when you increase an excise tax
the individual sees that price in the
product when they purchase it if you
increase the sales tax it's added after
you purchase it as you know so an excise
tax is very effective to influence the
way people think about a product before
they purchase it because it's the price
that they see on the product so starting
in 2000 the total cost of a pack of
cigarettes in New York City was a dollar
58 okay so this is only thirteen years
ago so you look at this trend upward
increasing federal New York City and New
York State taxes up to 210 2010 now it's
11 dollars a pack it's one of the
highest costs for a pack of cigarettes
in the United States that's a lot that's
a huge change over time right and other
measures were introduced in New York
City as well and I like the slide
because it just really shows us the
trend over time and what happens each
time New York City introduced one of
these new measures that's part of this
empower instead of measures so we have
the about one in five people smoking all
the way up until 2002 2003 tax gets
introduced plummet smoke-free workplaces
plummet free nicotine patch distribution
so you call up and you get you know them
sent to your home continues to go down
we see a little bit of trending in the
same and then they really start hitting
again with hard core media campaigns
this is this complement of media with
the ability to act right this is where
we really use media to enable people to
make healthier choices increasing taxes
again federal taxes to go up new york
city taxes go up and you just see this
really beautiful trend down and this is
all simply through public policies this
is not about sitting down and talking to
your individual patients not that that
didn't happen because you're creating
sort of a buzz about it but these are
things that city government combined
also with federal and state government
could do and made a huge difference in
the use of tobacco so let's move to
another country or Y which had one of
the highest rates in America certainly
in terms of overall smoking 33 percent
in 2006 smoked they came in and they
just introduced the entire package right
and look at this plummet in 3 years
one in four smokers quit that's pretty
remarkable in a country these are the
kinds of things that can happen
when we introduce in a standardized way
and use the regulation and enforcement
capacity that we have as nations and as
a global community to make a difference
on the non communicable disease
environment moderating risky behaviors
that were individual choices but
certainly facilitated to be different
when you create an environment that
allows it to change so the lessons
learned from this approach was
innovating approaches to expanding the
impact should be innovative sorry
innovative approaches to expand me app
it should be utilized and I again
mentioned the FCTC as a model it's not
necessarily appropriate for all but it's
really thinking about how do we create
evidence-based packages export them and
help support their implementation and
then this idea of packages themselves
having just a huge impact finally I want
to talk very quickly about the clinical
environment and an interesting
initiative that we are starting to help
support and facilitate and the idea is
to change the control of blood pressure
through enabling clinical care decisions
that are best choices for patients and
that help support patients best choices
so I talked a little bit before about
hypertension treatment considerations
and how complicated it can be and some
of so that varies by the environment
that we're working in in the healthcare
system that we have and there are
different guidelines that exist and in
not only at the national level but
within healthcare institutions at the
United States are variations is J and c7
and someday there will be a J in c8 but
also other countries have different
versions that they use so people have
guidelines but there are some
commonalities of challenges which relate
to various for medication prescription
and adherence for patients which is
really what it all comes down to right
that's what our opportunities are tell
them to change their lifestyle or to
give them an effective medication but
that medication will make no difference
unless they take it so the issues
related to medication treatment our
availability of those medications the
affordability of those medications and
the complexity of the regimens that were
asking patients to follow and then there
are also barriers to the effective
treatment delivery of those medications
so it's the algorithms that providers
are being asked to follow that can be
quite complicated and another example is
just inadequate patient follow-up as I
discussed before like how do you get the
person back in how do you get them to
take their medication how do you get
them in the community to continue to
follow the recommendations you've made
some really interesting opportunities to
learn from what's been done with respect
to tuberculosis and that's one of the
models that were really thinking about
now because we we should be learning
from successes as an infectious disease
these are not totally different
environments that we're working in so
with respect to tuberculosis one of the
things that they did with standardized
treatment right so there's like no
matter where you are in the world there
are sets prescribed set of medications
that you should take if you have TB to
be treated and one of the advantages of
that is when you have a set sort of core
set of medications that are expected to
be used you drive demand and you drive
supply and you have the opportunity to
leverage that and make those very
broadly available the other thing that
they've done T in TB was really think
about as structured a structured
approach aimed at high quality
standardized care ultimately that they
hold themselves accountable for each
patient and for the outcome of that
patient
they set targets and indicators and they
do a lot of data collection evaluating
and reporting this is a little bit the
way we think about patient registries
panel management in the in the current
clinical environment and then they use
that information around targets and
indicators to define and further actions
and and create additional indicators so
this is a framework created for
tuberculosis I will acknowledge that TB
is not well controlled everywhere in the
world but this is an approach of
standardizing and simple about
simplifying it and maybe we can use that
idea of standardized and simplified
globally when we talk about hypertension
so the opportunities in the
pharmacologic treatment of hypertension
similar to what we just talked about
with TB would be identifying a core set
of medications not necessarily that only
those medications would be available but
could we set a core set of medications
one diuretic not just any diorite but
one diuretic could we identify a single
diuretic that's available everywhere so
that when the patient runs out they're
not switched to a different one right
can we make those medications available
everywhere and then can we find the key
elements of care delivery that makes us
effectively to deliver care and so the
global standardized hypertension
treatment is an initiative that we are
helping support and that we are just
launching now out of the CDC working
collaboration with the pan-american
Health Organization and we're also
working with state key stakeholders
across the Americas first to pilot in
this region and then to help expand it
out globally the purpose is to support a
strategy and framework
standardizing hypertension
pharmacological treatment that would
have worldwide applicability we're not
touching the the lifestyle area but it's
an important critical area but this
specific project has just focused on the
medication and the goal is that it would
support existing evidence-based
guidelines for diagnosis of treatment of
hypertension we're not trying to
harmonize the way people you know what
blood pressure they treat to how they
select people who need to be treated
that's all up to the countries as long
as it's an evidence-based approach and
it's standardized it's fine what we're
trying to do is complement it with
making sure that the medications that
are being integrated into those
guidelines are available affordable and
that the patients get those medications
delivered in a way that helps support
them continuing the care the lessons
learned from initiating this is that we
can certainly extend support for the
best decisions in the clinical
environment the same way we think about
the best decisions in the community
environment for us as consumers in his
residents and so that clinical care
really is a population approach and we
should think of it that way we should
increase in lis think of it thinking of
it that way with respect to the
Affordable Care Act certainly we should
think about it as we plan forward also
in low middle-income countries also that
effect of chronic care management is
something that we can aspire to globally
and that it's relevant in low middle and
income high high-income countries a lot
of the work that we do in low
middle-income countries is focusing on
population effects but we should not
neglect the fact that there needs to be
a very strong and robust clinical
environment to complement that and more
or less as I'm sure to come because this
is a this is early in this process so in
summary to reduce this risky behavior
that we started with thinking about
individuals making we really need to
make the Healthy Choice the easy choice
and it's all about making the Healthy
Choice the default so as we move forward
we need to think about multi sector
engagement in developing initiatives we
need to think about a robust learning
community about sharing information and
how critical that is not only in the
United States but globally we need to
innovate with solid evaluation of those
models we need to think about developing
models that are scalable we shouldn't
spend our time coming up with
interesting models if they're not
something that can be ramped up to reach
these broader populations and the
absolute should be evidence-based or
evidence-informed we should think about
ways to do rapid dissemination when we
find solutions
we need to find mechanisms to sustain
and this is where government we become
so key as long-term investors in the
countries in which they're responsible
for and then I think what it all comes
down to is data because while it's about
saving lives
we won't know about who we're saving
unless we understand who they are and
all of that comes from data systems so
thank you
right this is a challenge because I
think evaluation is really it's about
it's about investment to begin with so
any program or initiative it needs to be
anticipated that you want to evaluate it
so you build it into the budget and that
becomes a political discussion and a
question about value and the way in
which we in the government and and and
you as you write your proposals are able
to articulate the importance of
evaluation and I think it's absolutely
key and so we need to all reiterate in
our work how important not only the
project but the evaluation is and the
key underlying argument is that it's a
fiscal responsibility right because if
we're spending our money on things that
aren't having impact and we're being
fiscally irresponsible so an evaluation
isn't really an option it should be part
and parcel of any project in order to
make sure there's legitimate and should
be continued to be financed so that's
the argument for it
so the the challenges that we do need to
find ways to make sure that it's
affordable to do and this is where the
innovation comes in so I in New York
City when we initiated the trans-fat
initiative we wanted to reduce the use
of trans fat in restaurants but we need
to know what the level of use was in
restaurants there's no data for that
right so and there's no infrastructure
for collecting it but what we did do and
what we do know is that we have food
inspectors that go into restaurants
every single day I mean that's an entire
infrastructure that's already there so
the and we worked with them taught them
how to assess if there's trans fat in
food and taught them how to collect it
and sent them out into the field to
collect that data so I think that's an
example of how we need to think about
using the infrastructure that already
exists so that we find cost-efficient
ways to collect data because if you go
into low and middle-income countries
right now there are a million surveys
going on constantly huge investments in
surveys this organization this interest
some money and so they're doing all of
these surveys and we do them in the
United States too and I can't help but
think we could be much more cost
efficient if we actually sat together
and said let's just do one survey or
let's do two so reason we'll put all of
this information in there together so
the second point there requires planning
and the third piece is that in
particularly the clinical environment
there's a lot of data that's there
that's just simply not being used so
before we think about collecting new
data the question is what is the
existing data that's there that's
already exist that we can use as an
evaluation
what about these so vehement process who
my understanding is that because he kind
of actors do such low quality
ingredients that they have to use sodium
to make it palatable so I'm curious
about this conversations they have with
them they have natural common interests
well I saw I think I I think the reality
is it's never as simple as it may seem
so it's true that cost that sodium is a
low cost flavor enhancer but is not the
only flavor enhancer and it's not the
only way it's not the only reason that
70s use so for example in bred sodium
actually tight rates the rate with which
the yeast acts and so it really serves
more in the manufacturing process to
figure out how quickly you can make your
bread which doesn't necessarily have to
do with the cost of sodium in the bread
or the taste of the sodium in it right
so there's different reasons that sodium
is use so I think first of all from we
as healthcare if those of us working in
the public health environment we need to
understand the motivations and the
reasons in which different actors are
making specific decisions because I
think your your comment is is true in
some conditions but not necessarily true
in others so until we actually figure
all of that out we can't come with
solutions to work with them on it and
the other piece is that when it comes to
economics the base price where the
immediate profit isn't only the only
motivator of many companies and
corporations because they to operate in
our community and they to have long-term
interests in being viable and so there
are definitely different reasons for
doing many different things so I think
ultimately the goal is to find out where
that common area of interest is and to
work around the commonalities but to be
very transparent about where the
potential conflicts are so that there is
no either perceived a real conflict of
interest when the final decisions are
being made if everybody knows why
they're at the table then then people
can look with transparency
the decisions will be made
what kinds of interventions can be
specifically
towards children taking in the era of
social media and different ways of
communication
in the future public
yeah so I think this question of how we
tailor population approaches to
different subpopulations of interest is
a really complicated one but also a
really important one they have because
there are cost efficiencies when we do
one intervention for everyone but that
doesn't necessarily mean that it reaches
everyone and in fact we may after they
be existing health disparities if we're
introducing interventions assuming that
don't have the same impact on all
populations and they don't so when we
talk about children that means and and I
definitely the the bias and the data
that I presenting as an adults a lot of
the again a lot of the data that we have
is in adults because you can collect
data in adults and in children it
becomes more complicated news you have
to get special permission and the data
sources are a little different so that
may have a little bit to do with the way
we present and think about these things
but for tobacco for example and a lot of
these salt reduction you know you can
talk about food you can talk about adult
decision making a lot of what kids eat
at home it's what parents are cooking
for them and so even baby food you might
recall where you know moms would taste
dads would taste the baby food before
they gave it to the baby if it tasted
good to them then they thought it tasted
good to the baby but if your palate is
already expecting you know tons of salt
you're just gonna be passing along that
habit that expectation to your child so
it's something we do really need to
think about and sort of break up as we
move forward in terms of interventions a
lot of the work around the younger
generation has been focused on school
environments because those are captive
audiences and that's a place where
children are for eight or more hours and
so when when we talk about physical
activity initiatives food initiatives
education and also using children to
disseminate message
to parents about hypertension control
that's a really really interesting
environment I think that's where a lot
of the innovations have occurred also
because it's efficient to reach children
the matter
yeah so it's a really very important
question I think that what it comes
right down to is that we you know we're
a democracy and the government city
state and federal government exists
because it has the endorsement of the
people and the rights that we have and
the authorities that we have as
government that they've given to us
historically the establishing of a
nation and over time so in New York City
the Board of Health has the right to
regulate on all things related to health
now that's huge right so the board what
how do we define you know where health
ends I mean one could argue that that
could expand into many different areas
of the economy even because you can make
a health argument there the question is
how that's interpreted over time and so
every time a new initiative is
introduced there is the potential that
one might think because it's a
population approach that it may limit
individual choices I think it's up to
those people in government to explain to
citizens how it may or may not be the
case and then ultimately it is up to the
population to make the decision so you
see these things working their way
through court systems appropriately and
legitimately and ultimately the decision
is made by the by the port or it may be
made by the Board of Health or it may be
made informally or formally and other
appropriate policy settings so it's
different for everyone and I think
ultimately it's up to those that are
introducing and proposing the
initiatives to think very carefully
about how they affect individuals as
well as populations at large so that
they can be prepared to respond to those
questions